bonsoir je suis très content d'être avec
vous félix fribourg le seul tlx lui à
plus de speaker et d'organisateurs
quêtes publiques
le thème de ce thé xx est le leur bon
changement de carrière
et souvent ces événements sont organisés
un pont crescendo avec un feu d'artifice
final pas aujourd'hui désolé non moment
changement de carrière c'est pas très
très impressionnant s'est pas ronald
reagan qui passe d' acteurs à président
des états unis s'est même pas yannick
noah qui passe de bon tennisman à
mauvais chanteur moi j'étais étudiant à
hec et je suis devenu humoriste
voilà donc la seule différence c'est
qu'avant je racontais des conneries à
l'oreille de mon voisin maintenant je
raconte des conneries dans un micro et
puis on me donne de l'argent enfin pas
aujourd'hui mais d'habitude donc par
rapport à ali qui a fui la guerre
moi j'ai fui l'auditoire c'est pas le
même niveau de bravoure donc je me sens
pas tout à fait légitime être debout
devant vous et parlez et encore moins
légitime de gentiment moqué de tous les
intervenants avant moi mais je vais le
faire quand même hein on a commencé
alain alors alain il est passé de membre
du groupe de rock the young gods à
joueur de sitar
je pense que ça fait moins de groupies
quand même moi j'ai jamais autant
d'idées mal à discuter dire tu préfères
le chanteur guitariste un nom à celui
qui à la cithare laser est ravi shankar
qu'était le joueur de sitar le plus
connu de l'histoire sa fille c'est norah
jones
donc elle incite à une fille mais je
veux bien son numéro un
on a eu ensuite christophe christophe
chabot denis charlet fait rejeter
barrès voir tome rien ne vaut également
pour baragouiner une phrase merci
l'éducation vaudoise
m me christophe il est électro pasteur
je pense que c'est le seul pas beaucoup
de collègues bond remarqué jésus il
était bien charpentier donc c'est
franchement bon à la fin de sa carrière
il aimait - le bois quand c'est pas toi
qui tiens le marteau c'est moins rigolo
tout de suite 1 er christophe sait que
s'il veut aider quelqu'un à trouver la
lumière soit il peut lui parler de jésus
soit il peut changer l'ampoulé donc il
est la plupart des gens qui entame une
carrière religieuse souvent c'est parce
qu'ils ont vécu une expérience
extraordinaire
christophe il a mis les doigts dans la
prise en main je n'ai vu tony chopper
the sound et ensuite on a eu besoin
benoît j'ai beaucoup aimé ta
présentation et un truc qui m'a dérangé
c'est que tu nous a mis un slide une
très jolie femme et après tu nous as dit
fermer les yeux j'étais un petit peu
frustré bon après j'ai fermé les yeux tu
as fait un truc de relaxation je les
aient rouvert c'est à mon tour de parler
donc c'était assez efficace j'ai bien
aimé quand a dit penser un moment de
bonheur intense comme la naissance d'un
enfant ça se voit juste que c'est pas
toi qui accouche
ensuite on a eu ali alors alice un
témoignage très touchant qu'on m'a
traduit ça nous montre quand même qu'on
a un petit peu de boulot à faire en
termes de pays d'accueil
c'est un type qui fuient la guerre comme
ça qui fait cette route si difficile et
qu'on enferme pendant cinq ans dans un
village en suisse allemande d'un moment
ils devaient se dire que la guerre
c'était pas si horrible que c'est la fin
j'ai de la peine pour lui comme moi y'a
tellement bon bah c'est que maintenant
il est libre il s'est installé à thoune
tu as fait 4000 kilomètres encore un
petit effort phase t plus très loin la
20 km est du bon côté du rucher graben
continuerai bien et il a son passeport
suisse à lier ça je trouve qu'ils le
méritent vraiment déjà parce qu'il parle
beaucoup mieux allemand que moi et
surtout parce que j'ai pas tout compris
mais il a dit au moins quarante cinq
fois le mot arbeiten donc c'est bon ils
le méritent
son passeport suisse et si j'ai bien
compris à lille aimerait retourner à
l'université depuis 19 ans et on le
laisse pas se dire qu'il ya des gamins
qui sont nés quand il a demandé la
première fois qui maintenant sont à
l'uni pilule ne l'ès pas voilà c'était
pas une blague ce juge pour qu'on se
rende compte à quel point on est con un
sitting adel merci madame
c'est à peu près ce que ça méritait
si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je serai
sur la même scène cadel des to be free
j'aurais sans doute répondu adèle
c'était le troisième reste à moi
j'adorais ce nom mais c'était quand même
choisi un nom qui comporte le seul mot
anglais qu'aucun francophones arrivent à
prononcer moi quand j'étais gamin on
pouvait pas parler de ton groupe sont
positionnés à la gueule de tous ses
potes
c'était formidable et je trouve
vachement intéressant de savoir comment
tu as pu rebondir après un succès aussi
fulgurant qu'éphémère tu aurais pu
totalement sur les secteurs et devenir
chanteur mais non l'aviation d'affaires
c'est assez ironique parce qu'à l'époque
toutes les filles voulaient s'envoyer en
l'air et que les to be free et
maintenant c'est les hommes d'affaires
qu'ils le font donc et bien sûr christ
alors là j'étais enfin je me suis senti
un peu insignifiant parce que c'est là
que tu te rends compte que dans ta vie
ta pas vraiment eu des obstacles et moi
je suis né mais dans ma tête et avec un
core 2 mecs
enfin c'est pas le corps de ryan gosling
mais tu fais ça fait la faire et c'est
que tu dis dieu il doit quand même enfin
c'est quoi son propre schéma christophe
que nous avons le talent mais il fait
naître des gens avec le genre qui
correspond pas au sexe qui picolent il
se trompe de ligne qu'est-ce qui fait
fait vieux donner un pénis à une femme
ça sert à rien donné du dentifrice ans à
canards il va pas s'en servir enfin
savall encombré donne ce pénis 1,1 des
mecs à kita fils et un vagin fin faut
quand même être sûr
donc voilà je les écoute tous ces
témoignages et je crois que j'ai
rarement est aussi mal à l'aise de ma
vie de dire je dois monter sur scène me
moquer d'eux et après parler de moi je
pose que simon millions dernier c'est
pour m'humilier et pour que pendant la
journée je me dise tiens ce que je veux
pas changer de carrière une deuxième
fois avant de monter sur scène pour que
ce soit plus impressionnant a raconté
alors je voulais vous dire vous êtes les
premiers chiffres et boire ça va je vais
aller en jetpack sur la lune
on ne va pas le faire c'est beaucoup
trop fatigante et c'est pas moi en fait
c'est comme ça que je prends mes
décisions
j'ai un modèle de dissidents qui est
basée sur l' envie de l'homme les envies
que j'ai de faire les choses
est ce qui ce qui détermine si je le
fais ou pas c'est ce seuil laquelle le
seuil de flemme
voilà et c'est comme ça que je prends
une fissure donc on voit que faire un
thé tôt que j'avais envie mais pas assez
pour le faire et après on m'a contacté
j'ai dit oui du coup j'étais obligé de
le faire et avec ce deuxième élément on
voit que je fais ces trois actions et
donc voilà on m'a demandé de venir un
peu parlé aussi de mon changement de
carrière
si je vous fais la version courte en
gros bas j'ai réalisé que j'avais plus
envie de raconter des conneries que
d'être assis derrière un bureau à
essayer de pas en faire du coup je suis
devenu humoriste et ça a marché
voilà mais je sais quand eto'o que c'est
pas ça de nos jeux je sais qu'un tête
tant que c'est pas ça qu'il faut donner
un peu plus de détails et tous qu'il
faut donner deux trois anecdotes
personnelles une ou deux formules qui
font sourire qu'il faut essayer
d'inspirer les gens et qu'il faut faire
pour l'instant j'ai trouvé que le truc
des mains non donc il ya un truc
peut-être que j'ai penché pas comment
inspiré avec ce que j'ai fait parce que
j'ai pas envie que des gens deviennent
humoriste possible à cette concurrence
donc ça je vais pas je vais pas vous
encourager à le faire mais des trucs qui
s'applique un peu peut-être plus
généralement j'ai l'impression qu'en
suisse c'est peut-être par ailleurs mais
c'est le pays que je connais mieux on a
un petit peu un manque d'ambition et
d'originalité dans moment des choix de
carrière et j'ai l'impression que par
rapport à ce modèle on surestime nos
obligations et on en invente certaines
alors les impôts ça s'est passé il faut
faire ça c'est pas vous pouvez pas y
couper
sauf si vous êtes très très riches et
que vous connaissez un avocat genevois
là c'est bon il ya pas besoin mais
faites-le mais les autres obligations je
me sens quand on a un truc très suisse
et la convenance le consensus
on nous dit à 6 ans quand on colorie
qu'il faut pas dépasser puis on oublie
de me dire à 20 ans maintenant vous
pouvez dépasser c'est bon on reste dans
un espèce de deux cadres et je dis pas
qu'il faut tous acheté un caissier et
puis tag est un anarchiste au tipex sur
un sac eastpak puis dire le système est
pourri mais peut-être que ce serait pas
content se poser la question est ce que
ma vie et ma profession me plaît avant
ses 30 ans j'ai fait exprès de prendre
30 ans je prends je suis un des rares
dans la salle à être en dessous comme ça
vous sentez tous vieux maintenant
et moi et moi je pense que mon parcours
c'est un exemple de ce qui peut se
passer quand on se pose les bonnes
questions au bon moment vous avez vu
comme gillard sûr de moi quand j'ai dit
ça on aurait dit steve jobs à une
conférence apple quand je sais plus quoi
je parlais non voilà moi donc quand
j'étais petit je voulais être
contrôleurs de train il faut que j'aille
vite parce que mon grand-père était
contrôleur de train et puis je l'aimé
bien et puis après j'ai réalisé que
c'était chiant et à l'adolescence je
voulais être rappeur j'étais persuadé
d'être noir voilà
et ouais et après j'ai réalisé que
j'avais pas le sens du rythme et que
habillée comme ça je n'allais jamais
perdre ma virginité donc usé j'ai arrêté
assez rapidement et j'ai pas trop quoi
faire et je faisais des bonnes notes à
l'école et du coup les profs me dis que
je vais faire des études
parce que quand tu fais des bonnes notes
on dit qu'on va faire des études et
quand on fait des mauvaises notes
les profs disent qu'il faut choisir un
métier et c'est important de faire des
études je trouve si on a l'opportunité
parce que ça permet de se trouver un peu
au même si on sait pas trop ce qu'on
étudie comme c'était le cas pour moi et
puis aussi de repousser le moment
d'entrer dans la vie active que ça
arrivera bien assez vite
et oui ça coûte cher à la collectivité
mais ma génération on va passer notre
vie à payer vos retraites
et quand on sera l'âge de la retraite
aura plus rien aucun arrêté de nous
casser les couilles mais souvent du coup
cantonné aux études on se pose pas la
question de ce qu'on va faire de notre
vie parce que c'est la question la plus
flippante du monde qu'est ce que je vais
faire de ma vie
pour moi c'est dans le top 3 avec est-ce
que j'ai éteint le gaz en partant et
est-ce que tu prends la pilule
non mais c'est violent parce que dans
une vie qui sait faire de ta vie moi
parfois je décide de faire un truc chez
moi je vais dans une autre pièce puis
après 30 secondes j'ai oublié ce que je
suis venu y faire l on me demande ce que
je faire pendant les 40 50 60 prochaines
années c'est absolument impossible
surtout que j'ai l'impression est
aujourd'hui un intermède exemple que
maintenant on choisit plus pour une vie
on choisit ce qu'on veut faire comme
projet comme trajectoire comme tranches
de vie et on fait des pauses on s'arrête
il ya des métiers qui qui qui qui change
y en a deux qui sont inventés d'autre
n'existe plus je pense il est un
spécialiste de minitel dans les années
tu as eu intérêt à prendre internet
assez vite quand même parce que 36 15
rue lazare plus à rien quand tu peux
aller sur alta vista chercher cindy
crawford
il n'y avait pas encore youporn et
google et donc moi je trouve c'est
beaucoup plus rassurant de se dire
qu'est ce que je vais faire pendant les
1 2 5 12 prochaines années douze années
ces trois coupes du monde sa fin
il ya certains il y aura certains des
mêmes joueurs donc surtout dans l'équipe
suisse donc on arrive à seurre on arrive
à se représenter je trouve c'est une
bonne mesure et du coup la fin de mes
études j'ai réalisé que je sais j'avais
pas envie de bosser là dedans j'avais
pas envie de bosser dans la banque la
finance
comment comment dire ça sans vexer la
première industrie de suisse c'était
plutôt mon plan b z et je me suis à vous
de nous tourner vers les philosophes et
je me suis demandé qu'est ce que j'aime
faire et j'ai réalisé que j'aimais bien
quand les gens rigolaient j'aimais bien
écrire et du coup je me suis dit est ce
qu est un métier qui combine ces deux
choses pour moi et maurice tu étais pas
un métier ne s'était pas dans les
fascicules d'orientation professionnelle
ça passait directement deux hôtesses de
l'air à huissier de justice donc c'était
oui huissier de justice ses avants mais
ne laissez pas la vérité venir au
travers d'une bonne blague et et pour
moi c'était pas un truc pour moi je
voyais les humoristes à la télé ils
savaient chanter il savait danser jouer
la comédie souvent ils étaient beaux je
regardais la télé française et et moi
j'ai ce visage qui a plus ou moins la
palette émotionnelle d'un tétraplégique
et ses méchants et ses méchants pour les
tétraplégiques et après j'ai découvert
les humoristes anglais les humoristes
américains et du coup j'ai j'ai commencé
à écrire et en même temps je veux c'est
que mon comptable puisque a dit pierre
et et plus je faisais de la compta plus
j'ai réalisé qu'il fallait que l'humour
ça marche et l'entreprise pour laquelle
je faisais d'un conte a fait faillite
donc le choix s'est imposé suis devenu
humoriste professionnels y à peu près
quatre ans et demi je suis vraiment
désolé mais je vais dépasser et du coup
ça fait 80 mx fais ce métier je pense
que deux fois par jour on pose la
question suivante alors non
et je vais passer dans les rangs tout à
l'heure si si vous pouvez faire un petit
geste peut manger rien mangé depuis
lundi non j'ai de la chance j'ai
commencé bénévolement à prête à les
cacher un peu symbolique après un peu
plus maintenant ça marche très très bien
je suis pas riche je pense qu'avec mes
choix de carrière je le deviendrai
jamais si j'accepte de venir
gratuitement à fribourg mais mais j'ai
suffisamment de côté pour que le jour où
j'ai fini de vexer toute l'europe
j'ai un petit peu de côté avant de me
retrouver à la rue et puis après je
ferai autre chose je sais pas je dirais
construire une yourte je deviendrai
pasteur et je referai un tev tôt pour en
parler mais j'aimerais un peu terminé sa
route est un peu plus générale de dire
que l'argent j'ai besoin qu'on y pense
trop j'ai l'impression que l'argent
c'est c'est bien mais le temps c'est
mieux non parce que là j'ai pas j'ai pas
trouvé de citations de rappeurs parce
qu'ils aiment tous d'argent donc j'ai
pas trouvé un rappeur qui critiquent l
argent donc j'ai dû reprendre de mes
vieux texte non c'est peut-être des cas
extrêmes mais moi j'ai l'impression que
j'ai certains amis qui travaillent dans
l'audit dans les banques qui sont une
espèce de spirale infernale huibers 60
70 heures par semaine
il gagne 8 9 10 mille francs par mois à
notre âge et ils ont ils sont obligés de
commander les trucs sur internet qui se
font livrer au bureau parce qu'ils vont
plus à la maison et on se demande
vraiment si c'est ça qu'il faut faire si
aller comme ça on va pas se retrouver à
90 ans enfin soyons honnête et que mon
hygiène de vie à 70 ans et et se dire ah
ben merde c'était nul en fait est
retourné à la sauvegarde de nos ventes
nos trente dont 40 ans parce que dieu
m'ait et du coup je me dis est-ce qu'on
réfléchit pas à l'envers est ce qu'il
faudra pas mieux se demander comment on
va vivre une autre vie peut-être de se
demander comment on va la gagner
et oui on dirait un peu une citation de
paul aux colocs et surligne c'est à g
d'une fille de 15 ans et c'est pour ça
que voilà je les sais pour votre in-stat
g si jamais
mais je trouve ça important de se poser
cette question là parce que de trouver
un truc vraiment qui se fait plaisir
tous les matins et moi c'est me
recoucher donc j'ai j'ai trouvé un
métier où c'était possible et je suis
vraiment content de ça et non mais alors
il ya peut-être des gens dont c'est la
vocation d'être comptable j'en ai
rencontré
ne leur parlez pas mais mais il ya
beaucoup de gens faisant qui se
résignent qui vont au boulot le matin en
attendant le soir le lundi en attendant
le vendredi à la rentrée en attendant
les vacances et puis la retraite la
préserve à la retraite et ils savent
plus comment dépenser tout ce temps
qu'ils ont tout à coup donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut quand même se
pose la question et c'est d'être
extrêmement pourris gâtés et naïf de se
dire ça parce que je sais qu'à plein de
gens qui sont coincés dans des boulots
qui n'ont pas l'occasion de changer
parce qu'ils sont obligés mais j'ai
l'impression que surtout quand on est
jeune on peut vivre avec beaucoup moins
d'argent que ce qu'on croit et quand on
enlève cette contrainte là nous envient
deviennent beaucoup plus clair et
surtout j'ai beaucoup de potes je me
semble leurs loisirs ils les préfèrent
alors métier milan ferait jamais leur
métier de ce qu'ils ont à présent que
c'est pas possible
moi je pense qu'il faut essayer et faut
pas ici à moitié faut essayer à fond je
me suis tourné vers les autres
philosophes modernes qui sont les
humoristes et c'est important ça sera
important de bien travailler et d'être
sympa avec les gens parce que si tu es
lionel messi ou rihanna tu peux être un
connard parce que les gens sont obligés
de travailler que toi il n'y en a qu'un
de chaque
mais si t'es pas lionel messi soit sympa
avec les gens ça ça passe par un rien se
rappeler d'un prénom c'est dire bonjour
c'est faire un sourire une petite blague
parce que les gens il préfère bosser
avec quelqu'un s'ils ont le choix on
bossait avec quelqu'un de compétent et
sympa ou de compétent qui est un connard
ils vont choisir assez facilement le mec
sympa et et soyez aussi sympa ce qui
n'est pas le cas sur cette photo avec
vous même et c'est ma dernière citation
je vais terminer là dessus parce que
parfois on est extrêmement dur avec soi
même mais il faut pas oublier voilà que
personne d'autre ne sait ce qu'on fait
exactement on est tous un peu paumé on
fait tous des conneries je crois que
cette photo de wicked the veil c'est un
assez bon exemple
et du coup il faut il faut pas être trop
dur avec soin il faut il faut se laisser
échouer de temps en temps et il faut se
dire que personne peut prédire l'avenir
on peut écouter tout l'été coupe du
monde ne sera jamais de quoi sera fait
demain surtout si c'est le bien qu'on
écoute et
et moi la moitié du temps je sais pas ce
que je fais mais qu'est-ce que je me
marre et j'espère que vous êtes un peu
marre et aussi merci beaucoup de m'avoir
écouté